maybe maybe to go back to your uh to
your aliens i guess the one thing i
often wonder about aliens is would they
have the same
fundamental physics ideas as we if we
have in mathematics would their math you
know would they
you know
how how much is this really intrinsic to
our minds if you start out with a
different kind of mind when you end up
with a different
ideas of what fundamental physics is or
what or what the structure of
mathematics is so this is why like if i
was uh
you know i like video games the way i
would do it as a curious being so first
experiment i'd like to do is run earth
over
many thousands of times and see if our
particular
um no you know what i wouldn't do the
full evolution i would start at homo
sapiens first and then see the evolution
of homo sapiens millions of times and
see how the the ideas of science would
evolve like would you get
like how would physics evolve how would
math evolve
i would particularly just be curious
about the notation they come up with
yeah um every once in a while i would
like throw miracles at them to like to
mess with them and stuff and then i
would also like to run earth from the
very beginning to see if evolution will
produce different kinds of brains that
would then produce different kinds of
mathematics and physics and then finally
i would probably millions of times run
the universe over to see what kind of
what kind of environments
and what kind of uh life would be
created to then lead to intelligent life
to then lead to
um theories of mathematics and physics
synthesis the full range and like sort
of uh like uh darwin kind of mark okay
it took them uh
what is it
uh several hundred million years to come
up with uh
calculus
i would just like keep noting how long
it did and get an average and see see
which ideas are difficult which are not
and and then and then conclusively
sort of figure out if it's uh
if it's more collective intelligence or
singular intelligence that's responsible
for shifts and for big phase shifts and
breakthroughs in science
if i was playing a video game and
got a chance to run this whole thing
you